wow
wow wow wow as goodbyes go get ready for
a nostalgia trip we made it huh
i'm sweetheart
returning to ramsay street to ensure
neighbours gets a fitting send off some
of the household names whose big breaks
came on the show i love you guys so much
congratulations on your wedding toadie
funnier sunnier than its british
equivalence in the late 80s neighbours
pulled in around 20 million viewers but
with audiences down to a million and a
new commitment to original drama from
channel five they pulled the plug
calling last orders at the waterhole
being best down at the weddings big
responsibility
don't know why it wasn't picked up by a
streaming channel you know and to be the
first so yet to send another set another
trend neighbors to set another trend and
be the first soap to uh transfer over to
a streaming channel but didn't happen
charlene get out of there
it was former bbc one controller lord
michael grade who gave it its tea time
billing some 37 years ago
thanks to his teenage daughter alison
who was told off for watching it in her
school break being the controller of
bieber what were you watching
she said we're all watching neighbors we
can't watch it because we're
oh i went into the office the next day i
said we're moving neighbors from 1 35 to
5 35
so the kids can watch it when they come
home from school and the rest is history
as they say
from the dulcet tones of angry anderson
at scott and charlene's wedding to the
psychedelic meanderings of bouncer's
dream not forgetting susan's sensational
slap i remember a woman calling out
from across the road in traffic just
calling out susan susan
you leave that
like okay
fans have promised a fulfilling joyous
finale a reward for those who remember
it so fondly
neighbours wouldn't have lasted 37 years
without the uk audience we're very very
appreciative and we hope and pray
fingers crossed that when you not watch
those last episode we will have done the
show proud and you'll be satisfied with
the way it ends
we might be leaving the street but we're
always going to be in each other's lives
always
this final slice of life down under
it'll go so quickly the end of an era as
fans say good day to ramsay street for
the last time
katy spencer sky news